Translator: Andrea McDonough
Reviewer: Jessica Ruby
What advice would you give to your 16-year-old self?
It is hugely helpful to love what you do
and to do something that you're interested enough in
that you can keep doing it forever
and not get bored with it.
But even things that you really love
are going to have hard, weird, lost moments
as you go through.
And so it's important to just,
as I said before,
just keep moving
and get through those moments
and realize that everybody has them.
And it's not because there's something the matter with you,
but just because you're doing something hard
and hard things are hard sometimes
but still worth doing.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.